MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
In this video, we talk about
nuclear binding energies.
But before we get
started on this topic,
I would like you to have a look
at this table or this diagram,
which shows nuclear abundances
in our solar system,
so how many atoms
of the various types
are present in our solar system.
And you see this super
interesting structure.
Most of it is hydrogen here.
And then there seems to be
some sort of an excess of iron.
And, you know, this table goes
all the way to lead and beyond.
There's a little
bit of a gap here.
So how is this possible?
How did this particle get
there in the first place?
Why is there some which are
more frequent than others?
A very interesting
question which
we will be able to answer
at the end of the discussion
of nuclear physics.
And the first starting
point is to understand
why nuclei are stable in the
first place, what holds them
together.
And that's the discussion
of binding energies.
So we can very simply write
the binding energy down.
We just sum up all the
ingredients, the number
of protons and electrons, times
Z, the number of neutrons, A,
the mass number
minus Z. And then
we subtract from this the
mass of the nuclei itself.
What remains is
the binding energy.
Just for record, the mass of the
proton, the mass of the proton,
the mass of the neutron,
you see that the neutron
is slightly heavier
than the proton,
and the neutron itself
decays into the proton.
A free proton does not decay.
However, inside the nucleus,
a proton can also decay.
And then we have the
mass of the electron.
You see there's a
factor of almost 2,000
between the mass
scales of an electron
and the mass of a neutron.
For all practical purposes,
we can ignore this,
but if it comes to
precision measurements,
then the mass of the neutron
which is 1/2 MeV becomes--
of an electron, which is
1/2 MeV, becomes relevant.
This plot here shows the
average binding energy
per nuclei as a function
of the mass number.
And you see that
with the exception
of those light elements,
you see that this
is fairly stable and in
the range of 7.5 to 9 MeV.
You also see that there seem
to be a maximum around iron,
which then leads to an
advantage in gaining energy
when you are--
gaining energy going
to lower-energy state
when you go in this direction
and in this direction.
This part is called fission,
this part is called fusion.
Both processes, because we go to
a more energy-preferred state,
are possible.
They can be used in
order to attain energy
from nuclear processes.
This diagram here
can be parameterized.
And the rest of
this video, we'll
talk about a very
popular parameterization
of the binding energy.
This is semi-empirical.
It's called the
Weizsager formula,
because it was proposed by
a German called Weizsager.
Sometimes it's called the
semi-empirical mass formula,
and sometimes the
discussion is summarized
in the liquid-drop model.
And you'll see why in a second.
What you see here is very
similar to where before we
can calculate the mass and
from that the binding energy
by having those
first elements here.
And this part then here
is our binding energy.
And there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 terms,
which we're discussing now
on the next slide.
What is shown here
is a parameterization
so you can fit the
data and get a best
estimate for the individual
parameters in this equation.
All right.
So as the name said,
liquid-drop model,
we can think about, in some
essence, about a nuclide atom
as being built out of a soup, a
liquid of protons and neutrons
which are bound together.
So the first term
which contributes
to the binding energy is
the so-called volume term.
This dominates the
binding energy.
And it's proportional
to the number--
the mass number.
Remember, the mass number is
proportional to the third power
of the radius,
hence proportional
to the volume of the nuclei.
And you know, this contributes
with about 16 MeV per nucleon,
per proton and neutron.
And from this, you can
conclude that the nuclear force
must be very short range.
Why is that?
Because in order for
the binding energy
to depend dominantly
on the volume,
the individual nuclei can
only see its nearest neighbor.
So this corresponds to a short
range force which is roughly
of the distance of two nuclei.
If any given nuclei would be
able to see everybody else,
we would see a term quadratic in
the number of nuclei available.
As a result of this, you can
calculate the central density,
which is about 0.17 nucleons
per cubic femtometers
or an average distance between
protons and neutrons of 1.8
femtometers.
OK.
So they are really
tightly packed.
The size of a proton
is about a femtometer.
All right.
However, the
protons and neutrons
which are on the surface
of this construct, they
see less nuclei--
they see less nuclei,
nucleons around him.
So therefore, the binding
energy needs to be reduced.
And it needs to be
reduced with the area
of the surface of the nucleus.
So they need to be proportional
to r squared, and therefore
proportional to A, the
mass number, to the 2/3.
OK.
Then the protons in the nucleus,
they are electrically charged.
So they are going to get apart.
And that itself also
reduces the binding energy.
So this is proportional to
the number of charges squared.
And then you normalize
this by the radius.
So charge squared over--
no, normalized.
Charge squared over r.
So this is q squared
over r, Coulomb term.
All right.
There's two more terms,
which are quite interesting.
The first one is
sensitive to the asymmetry
between the number of neutrons
and the number of protons.
And it can be explained by
the Pauli exclusion principle,
which allows only two
identical fermions, neutrons,
or two protons to occupy
the same energy state.
So you basically fill
up the energy states.
Now, as is shown in
this picture here,
you reach the
lowest energy state
if the number of neutrons
and the number of protons
is actually the same.
You have higher energies
if there is an asymmetry
between those two numbers.
But we have yet
another term which
is sensitive to the asymmetry
between the number of neutrons
and protons, which reduces
the binding energy.
And last but not least,
the pairing term,
which has a very similar origin.
So what we are looking
at here is the energy
is lower if you have an even
number of neutrons or protons.
It's higher when we
have an odd number.
So you can have an odd
number for the protons
or the neutrons, in
which case A is odd.
And the worst case, or
the worst energy state,
is achieved having both the
protons and the neutrons odd.
So that's why this is a little
bit more complicated way
to write this.
You have those three
different cases--
number of protons and
number of neutrons even,
A odd, or both Z and N odd,
in which case A is even--
just to add to the
confusion a little bit.
All right.
Then you can make a drawing
of the binding energy
as a function of the mass.
And you see, again, those
individual terms, the volume
energy, the volume
term here constant,
the volume plus surface
reduced, the volume plus
surface Coulomb further
reduced, and then
all terms put together here.
And you see again this binding
energy parameterization,
which we just discussed--
we saw the actual values.
There's a maximum
around here for iron.